oh it's an amazing day here in new york
city gorgeous weather and it is time for
baseball and today it's the new york
yankees against the tampa bay rays in
the final game of a three-game set from
yankee stadium to fox new york well the
big maple this is uh his fifth start of
the year and the
136th career start for this guy and you
see the numbers are getting better mike
rosso in that lead off spot for the rays
swinging and a miss doesn't hit well
against paxton right there
one away
paxton's feeling good he has a good
rhythm he is not even stepping off the
rubber
swing and a miss and a good pace it was
as he retires
the race quickly and in order another
raise going with the opener today and
that will be mr john curtis appearing in
his fourth game with the raise and his
first outing was against these yankees
he went two innings no hits no runs no
walks four strikeouts boyd homer in
three straight games he had a blast to
right field into the second deck
yesterday as nine home runs on the year
fly ball deep center margot back still
back on the track at the wall see ya
into monument park another home run for
voight four straight games and the
yankees lead one nothing so here's geo
orcella
and a cut and a miss to take care of her
two outs for the runner and second in
scoring position and that'll bring up
eric kratz uh you know if you can get
him to catch a good game and
the ball and play what else can you ask
for there you go put in play and you'll
find a hole
on the left side of the infield so kratz
picks up a single frazier moves to
second so he comes in to face tyler wade
fastball sky toward the line and left on
the run and meadows is there to make the
catch he had a long way to go and got
there early in the game two runners
aboard just one out that could be
a game changer and i know it's early but
this bowl austin meadows goes a long way
the sliding basket catch if that doesn't
go right that's gonna score at least a
run maybe two urchella who struck out in
the first inning
ripped down the left field line it's a
base hit for a shell it goes all the way
to the wall talkman is at third to hold
him there and a double for geo or
sheller
infield in torres at the plate second
and third one man out
it's turning in towards the catcher
immediately and then he has to open up
so that's knocked down by adamus he gets
torres at first scoring his talkman
and the yankees lead two nothing
hits the ball hard just couldn't find
the hole you know we noticed when torres
hit that ground ball that was knocked
down by adamus it wasn't even a close
play at first like he slowed down now
he's out of the game tell you what the
hits just keep on coming guys three and
two
the paxton's look good
six strikeouts as martinez goes down on
strikes and the rays go down in order
one two three he's retired seven in a
row renfro leads off the fifth in the
2-2
struck him out swinging high fastball
doing everything right throwing the
change throwing the breaking ball in the
change away and that was a blistering
fastball up strikeout number seven and
it's two on and one out joey wendell
coming up wild pitch allowing adamus to
go to third and there's a base head
headed toward the corner
adamus will score
margot heads to third they're going to
wave him home and the relay throw is not
in time
margot scores from first
and the rays have tied this game
joey wendell comes through
wendell shot that one up the left field
line he winds up at third base
so the two walks have cost
paxton and the rays take advantage and
come back to tie well here's mike browso
now a high fly ball back into left
ball at the track caught by talkman
so wendell tags and scores and the rays
take the lead
here's urshella one for two he doubled
to left this last time up
that one's driven deep to left field
there it goes
see ya
a two-run home run for urchella and the
yankees have retake the lead they're up
four to three
big hit for the yankees back to back
good at bats for rochelle maybe he's
gone all the way back
manuel margot
and this one is lined out of the reach
of wade and into left
diaz will score
and the rays on the base hit by margaux
have tied this game at four he continues
to have a great road trip at the plate
luis avalon to face joey wendell lefty
on lefty
window shoots this one down the right
field line that is a fair ball and
bounds back to frazier throw loose back
in
the raise will get a run that ball a
rocket off the bat and a rocket on the
rebound now mike zenino
that's a shot to left well tagged that
baby's gonna get out of here
home run for zanino
mike cenino a three-run blast scoring
margot and wendell in front of him
and the rays have a big inning here okay
so first and second for voight
that one is looped into right field
coming on bro so he's not going to make
the play
wade scores easily hicks moves to third
it's an rbi single for voight and the
yankees fighting back it's 8-5 raise
speaks against tywin
and a little
tap
played by zunino down to choi
sophia takes care of that shuts it down
one round scores eight five rays now one
on one out with the basement of brasso
at second base
and to right
back goes frazier and that ball is gone
home run
to the opposite field first home run for
yandy diaz
and the rays make it 10-5 but the rays
are one out away from going into first
place
on the ground that's choi
loop will cover and the rays have swept
the new york yankees at yankee stadium
winning this one 10-5